foreign
Dallas Texas and talk to Tori what's up
Tori
hey John it's so good to talk to you how
are you today I'm great how are you
I am wonderful
all right so you sent me OG a letter in
the mail
I did because I really wanted to get
your input on some things and help kinda
ease my mind or something well I get a
lot I get a ton of letters and I
actually read them and they bring me joy
they're usually full of like hey this
great thing happened I just want to say
thank you and your emails on my desk it
was like whoa so yeah there's a lot
that's expensive yeah all right so let's
let's start at square one and let's walk
everybody through it let's do it
oh gosh okay
learn more ran off with her Twitter
Affair and she loved her kids her
grandkids her husband of 33 years
and it was just a shock to everybody
so is this way out of character for her
oh yeah oh yeah she was the um
what you would picture as the country
Dunkin mama
she took care of all the kids that ran
around the town and everybody would show
up you know and get their kool-aids and
she was just that place that you would
go and Trust
and you know talk to or like I said just
hang out on the porch and drink Gatorade
or something like that and then tell me
about this Twitter this Twitter Romance
oh yeah I think I don't I don't even
know how long it was going on
uh but she just up and left one day she
left a bracelet that all the kids had
caught in her I'm sorry I'm postpartum
I'm probably gonna cry hey cry all you
want to even if you're not postpartum
that's all good man this is this is this
is
um
I mean on its face it's like there's no
way this happened and then like this
happened to a real family and this is
your favorite
and yeah it was it was insane so she
left her bracelet in her necklace at the
Kim Reynolds with this guy
we we didn't see coming didn't have a
clue we thought she was out for a run
but she never came back
um so hanging out all this happened like
two months before my husband and I got
married I've been a part of the family
for like 13 years now
um so so you know she was like my second
home
when you say
go ahead y'all were dating for 13 years
before you got married
no and we've been married for five years
now
um but she left right before we got
married okay so is she still gone after
five years with this Twitter Twitter
lover
yes so that like they made a go of it
this just wasn't like a bad decision and
six months later she came crawling back
or whatever
um yeah another part of the story she
came back three times
just in a matter of like six months and
I think one of it was like you know try
to put final things in order for her
divorce against my husband's dad because
he came in from work and the house was
absolutely trash of like paperwork he
beats to the house and stuff like that
so is it divorce final
wow okay
so five years ago
you're
now mother-in-law shocks everybody
and meets some dude on Twitter and runs
off and yeah it sounds two months before
our wedding right did she did she come
to your wedding I'm punched to my
husband
did she come to your wedding
so
but she didn't just leave she cut ties
she left things that your kids had got I
mean she she said I I want to no longer
be a part of this family right
what the heck was going on she sends a
text message to the oldest son
and the message said I didn't just leave
your dad I left all of you
okay so five years later
you write me
how can I help now
um
before before we come in I I want
everyone listening to this
um
it's so easy when you hear the sentence
he left her or she left him after 30
years she just she took off
I want everyone listening to hear five
years later the ripple effect that has
still continued to Rattle this family
the kids wondering what was it about us
that grandma left the husband that's
like whoa what's going on the
daughter-in-law who had a picture of her
life with this woman who suddenly right
so this thing rattles it isn't just a
matter of Oh Sheila
When anybody just leaves a family it
Everything Burns to the ground right
oh yeah
okay so how can I help you today I'm
just I'm so sorry
[Music]
um a few more details and a lot more
resentment toward her and so my question
is how do I accept her coming into my
home
she does not come into your home
she doesn't come into your home
you don't waste an ounce of energy on
resentment
she she looked at your table and said I
am cashing out my my seat here I'm out
it was her words to her own son that
said I'm leaving y'all too
cool okay okay I totally agree with that
but it is my husband's mother and he
still wants to have a relationship with
her
he has to put you first
and there comes a moment when you have
to say
not it's not about her
she needs to be moved off to the side
here where she asked to be put
it's about you looking at your husband
saying I don't want people in my house
who destroyed my husband I don't want
people in my house who are of such poor
character
and who are so low
that they would do that to their own
kids I don't want that type of person
around my children
and here's the kicker I feel unsafe when
your mom is in our presence
and then your husband has a choice
he can choose his mom
who left him
over his wife and then you'll have
bigger fish to fry
or he can do the right thing
and honor his wife
you see how this has very little to do
with mom this has very much to do with a
marriage right now
and this is a hard question I'm about to
ask you because this isn't what you
wrote about in your letter but how's
your marriage
say that again I I it was just a little
bit garbled I
all the time and if something comes up
you know I immediately go and talk to
him about it like hey let's look at this
this way
um we've used better help and even the
therapist on there he said I don't know
why y'all are calling me y'all are great
that's so good so so is is your husband
trying to reconcile something or is he
trying to prop up a fantasy
yes the the second I I really think he
just you know he had this picture of his
mom and his dad and this beautiful 33
years of marriage
and it was gone an instant yeah
in a weird way this may not be a perfect
one-to-one analogy
but
if his mom had died
he would have been able to grieve her
loss
but she asked
no she told the family y'all are dead to
me
exactly yeah
and so there's a ghost hanging on out
there that he can't fully let go of
yeah and and him and his siblings and
her you know they've gotten to a point
where they
um have this group chat and they're
always updating each other
and I tell him you know you need to back
off that because she doesn't care
if she cared she'd be here
's the hard part
you can only control you
yeah
and so
um
I would just be very clear about my
boundaries
and there's been a few moments in my
life when I'm gonna invite friends over
or and and they're I mean they're not
bad people they're just crass or
whatever they're but they're people I've
known for years and my wife has said I
do not want them around our kids
and I honored my wife because she was
right
and there's been times I told her I
don't want so and so around our family I
don't like so and so in my house
and she has said cool
I'm all in on us
and so you can't be you can you can do
whatever you want I would not spend my
energy trying to tell him what he should
or shouldn't be doing
I would be very clear about your safety
and your expectations for interactions
and dude I I'm I am I would love to talk
to your husband I'd love for him to call
in too
and I promise if he'll call in or write
it I know yeah he would be willing to do
that I mean like I said we're we're a
great community
if he wants to come in um uh stay on the
line and uh Jenna will give you direct
access that way we'll make sure we get
it
um that I'd love to have him on
but at the end of the day as hard as
this is he's got to choose his wife over
his mom
and quite honestly all of us have to do
that my mom's amazing
and my wife comes first
it's my wife
um it doesn't mean that I advocate my
responsibility to my mom that I somehow
less than oh but I I made a choice I
made a lifelong commitment to my wife
you throw on top of that a mom who has
just flat out evil and you ain't gonna
be around my kids
and I'd prefer our family to grieve this
loss finally with a period at the end of
it and walk away now
mom shows up at your front door
on her knees begging I screwed up I blew
up everything I ruined everybody's life
and I'm so sorry
and you want to start a multi-year
healing process maybe
but anything short of that Mom she told
me she was explicit she told you I'm
leaving y'all too
cool
I hate that for you
moms aren't supposed to leave
I'm so so so so so sorry
stay on the line we'll be uh we'll be in
touch